people pretty much know what the tactile
sensation is when you touch something
when you physically come in contact with
your body mainly your fingers and hands
and arms that sensation that your body
is aware of that object you're touching
is the sense of tactile response haptics
essentially the same thing we will be
demonstrating for haptic controllers
that we've devised and they came up
through essentially four intern projects
a summer one is we call the claw and it
essentially simulates the the sense of
grasp I can reach out and actually pick
things up and I have the the sense of
that it's a hard object or a soft object
so with the claw device I can just
extend my index finger and actually feel
that I've touched a virtual table where
the table doesn't exist and I can kind
of explore the contours of the cable
another device is called the haptic
revolver and it consists of another
handheld remote device has a drum on it
with various real textures as in the
poker example I can feel the felt table
I can feel the card plastic card and I
can feel the poker chip and the edge of
the poker chip yet another device is
called haptic links the links project
will actually join the two haptic
controllers mechanically
and the final project is called the
controller we thought gosh wouldn't it
be nice if we could offer a blind person
or a visually impaired person the sense
of VR such as it is for them so we have
instrumented a device that is worn by
the the VIP person that gives them all
the haptics of a cane rubbing or tapping
on things as well as 3d audio
[Music]
you